merci raphaël d'être là merci beaucoup
bonsoir raphaël et bien non sans
rappeler et annick et à témoin voilà
alors déjà c'est super merci syrie le
monde dans tous les hôtels raphaël qui
nous regardent qui nous regardent très
souvent à qui je fais un gros bisou
raphaël déjà envers si j'adore j'adore
c'est super c'est beaucoup alors je vous
en syrie le pouvoir
20h20 j'ai aujourd'hui toujours régné
vous contacté parce que déjà
j'aurais aimé ça fait longtemps que je
pense à vous parce que je voulais qu
invité sur le plateau se serait pas
passé comme ça mais je vous le dis mais
ça sera ses autres marques chaque gramme
alors vous parlez de votre fille
raphaëlle car là vous avez envie de la
rencontrer vous avez envie de lancer un
cri du coeur ce soir à messine sicile
non non non ça c'est important c'est ça
le plus important nous on n'est pas là
parce que oui avec moi une passion je
vais vous dire ça va commencer parce que
jamais gros sur le coeur
parce que moi j'ai même eu ma fille si
une telle pente en syrie vous avez des
enfants
il a fait comme un taureau sauvage
raphaël et bien j'ai pas vu depuis cette
année du cette histoire là où
malheureusement de cette voyante a dit
certainement de prendre le chèque à son
papa et moi malheureuse la gpa mais
c'est pas grave du tout parce que j'en
ai pas du tout à ma fille c'est moi je
n'étais pas super peur c'était pas super
père voilà à vrai dire même un mauvais
père de ce que j'ai vu au jamais boire
d'alcool dans la vie j'ai essayé pour
moi d'être bon père et je veux être mon
père et j'ai arrêté aussi j'avais des
problèmes d'alcool est arrêtée depuis un
an et demi alors là ce que vous avez vu
hier après c'est pas moi j'ai pas vu du
tout c'est tout elle rappelle que géant
tel qu'il ressort et voilà si je passe
par ici en photo et caméras je suis
désolé j'ai passé pas mal du tout un
passé pas mal de tous à rafael vous
inquiétez pas tout va bien raphaël juste
vous êtes
c'est du rock hip hop je veux avant tout
poser plein de questions pour moi c'est
très difficile parce que c'est un col
bâtiments abîmés et moi et j'ai perdu
toute ma famille et j'ai perdu ma vie
que j'aime et la petite fille et que
j'avais vraiment le très très vite qu'il
dit là bas tu me veux tu en aurais dans
le coma mais non mais non mais alors
afin non varin commencé du tout moi je
vous dis moi je préfère avoir votre
témoignage et vous me disiez c'est le
plus important que vous me disais que
vous aviez envie de revoir votre ville
vous n'avez pas vue depuis sept ans
carla et je pense que le plus ce qui
serait le plus important pour elle je
pense que ce serait raphaël peut pas
parler de ça je veux pas si vous voulez
que votre gauche pour avoir une petite
ma vie doit finir je les aime toujours
attendre oui ce qu'est ce qui s'est
passé pourquoi vous l'avez pas vue
depuis c'est ton carnac
qu'est ce qui s'est passé eh bien je
vais vous dire tout ça devant donc il
est allé voir cette voyante et qui vient
sortir d'actifs
vous savez ma fille c'est une fille moi
que j'ai essayé dans tous les cas
d'habitude avons regard à voir je suis
chrétienne j'ai toujours fait très
attention tous les vendredis au bal du
poisson j'ai toujours aidé et et de la
fille j'ai toujours essayé parce que
j'ai grandi avec la filière ceci sans
papa j'ai déjà j'ai eu pendant beaucoup
d'années avec ce marin habité par balles
dans l'ensemble après une séparation que
j'ai envoyée régulièrement tous les
quinze jours et après la bic avec moi
avant de partir dans les bars et y est
et là j'ai senti quelqu'un dre beats
avec moi car entre 15 et 17 ans un petit
bug je vous écoute cyril non mais rafael
audel on a été un petit peu coupé juste
ma file qu'est-ce que moi en ce sens
nous interroger sur la voyante ça qu'est
ce que vous voulez dire à carla ce soit
je voudrais bien car leur album 7e en
mai mais j'ai senti ma vie depuis
parce que tu veux bien que tu vas vis et
combessie et novak et de lure pour
erreur s'ils ont mal mais je voulais pas
parce que parce que tu vois j'ai je
voulais pas tom été pendant sept ans
j'ai pas vu se dit la vérité car là
c'est que tu as vu que je buvais je
voulais j'avais que si nous voyons
d'abord ce que katia au vote pour toi et
que tu as tout supporter pour moi mais
ça c'est toi de et je ne compte pas le
gars là les jeux me pardonne je leur
pardonne et saluons la phrase à dire que
je suis quelqu'un de pudique et tu vois
si les gens voulaient envie d'évoquer
les chroniqueurs ça arrive ne permet pas
du site papa ou aux îles à peine capable
par des fentes et moi j'avais cette
boule aux éditions en plus mais ma fille
je sais ma ville mais les choses
allaient raphaël moi ce que moi ce que
je pense j'espère que cette histoire sa
tête a pas mal pour un bien et que ça va
vous permettre de retrouver votre fille
car là vous allez pouvoir vous retrouver
et parce que je suis sûr que carlao si
elle a envie de retrouver son papa et
que alors je vais vous expliquer aussi
la coupure de ses 7 ans alors je vais
vous dire ça m'a vraiment plaisant betis
tchèque jeudi c'est accablant
j'ai lui coûtent deux fois il ya c'est
quoi cette histoire des fonds
nathaël c'est quoi cette histoire de
chèque l'été la noyade et a coûté
imaginez vous un album 17 ans moi j'ai
lu mais c'est un gars là je vais vous le
dire je la connais parfaitement s'il
voit qu'il est le père c'est une équipe
qui est trop gentil et brega chalon la
gtl et rouge 1-0 comme ça elles vont
n'importe quel d'honorer tous si tu ne
les utilisaient pour vous c'est pour ça
qu'elle a aucun sou sur le sur la banque
mais c'est pas ça s est fait embobiner
moi je vous le dit c'est partir si ses
maxis à messieurs donc elle est allée
voir s'ils voyagent sur l'échec c'est je
peux vous l'assurer et par contre ce que
je peux vous assurer les gardes à toute
la france
je vous garantis que carla elle voudrait
faire de mal à personne
adrien je vous jure c'est pas une vie
qu'il veut faire du ballon
mais peut-être que la popularité est
certaine ce que cette fable ii 7 ans
voyage vous savez donc pas de 17 heures
moi je suis cuisinier
j'apprends à des petits jeunes
l'apprentissage de la cuisine c'est
facile
elle a profité de leur pire elle a dit
son point faible moi j'avais de l'argent
à les toits comme temps que je me
rendais pas compte qu'ils vous voyez
graphiste c'est tout pour moi puisque
j'avais si tout pour elle vous voyez
c'était que tout perforé moi j'ai jamais
raphaël elle a payé la voyante avec
l'achat exactement ça va me payer la
voyante avec insert avec des chèques de
sonde
voilà c'est ça l'islam est voulu gm veut
pas du tout parce que certains et tout
d'un coup on fait des bêtises moi je
n'étais pas bien sur eux et moi la
passerelle est ce que vous êtes fiers de
votre fille de ce qu'elle a fait de son
parcours de paix c'est un mois d'affilée
mais je suis hyper perdre ma vie vous
savez chers qu'aux points chaque jour
vous avez voire de choc sont de l'avis
joindre deuxième outil était à venir
oui oui je dis oui de virer tout modèle
savoir ce que je fais alors j'ai dit oui
et oui qui est qui et quels agendas de
logiciels 24 à issy vous savez comme
elle est belle elle m'a dit qui est -
chattam giulani veut dire je t'aime de
deuxième wen vous savez pas qui s'est
bâtie dans lequel il baigne zhouqu la
neige compactée et g et valkyrie c'était
merdique à quimper mange tout comme
magali bertin et je respect de la
liberté
sipa que d'avoir balle parier parce que
je sais pas s'il est avec elle ou
citadin quand on regarde moi je ne doute
pas non mais non on vous demande pas en
tout cas que raphaël merci pour votre
cri du coeur moi ce pourvoi la route en
savoir plus et car elle sera avec nous
lundi et je pense que le message de son
papa va lui faire bien plaisir en tout
cas merci afin d'appeler ralentir on
vous reprend parce que oui raphaël et
surtout j'aimerais beaucoup cyril quand
vous n'êtes pas plus toujours adoré tous
les producteurs j'adore vers si raphaël
tu te voir si vous faites
doit tout le monde si vous payez fois un
petit cadeau que je puisse voir marcher
ma petite fille eh ben on va essayer on
va essayer de faire le plein avant la
fin c'est la gauche ne voit plus depuis
un an et demi
vous avez jamais vus tableur je recule
au foot à leur séquence à eux et ils se
font remonter la côte d'ivoire pour
essayer de rencontrer et toute ma vie si
tu n'es pas content mais au bout de ce
temps ci que chaque fois je m'écris
c'est parce que je l'avais tablas et si
j'ai pas vu j'oublie que je voulais
qu'ils voyaient perdre trois peut-être
parce que je suis amoureux de mercier je
lève et et est malheureusement j'étais
pas là et il dans mon coeur je veux être
là mais c'est terrible d'être parti
comme ça à cause de cette maladie
l'alcool pourrait servir voulu voir
toute ma vie je savais que j'aurais eu
des rafales ont souffert le match mais
on va faire le max graf à elle pour vous
faire ce beau cadeau d'accord mou rafael
il est urgent et des jeux suivants
d'arrêter des personnes étudiées précise
pour et je m'active un petit j'adorais
pour mercy raphaëlois faire le maximum
en tout cas on va essayer d'organiser ça
m